So let's start with postmodernism.
The first thing to understand about the
postmodernists are that they are by no
means unintelligent.
Quite the contrary.
Jacques Derrida,
for example,
and Michel Foucault for that matter,
too,
famous French public intellectuals who
are both at or near the head of what you
might describe as the postmodern
intellectual revolution,
are extraordinarily intellectually
capable.
Um,
that doesn't mean they're correct by any
stretch of the imagination,
but it certainly means that they're more
than able to put together a,
an argument that's difficult to
disentangle.
And so we'll start with the,
what I think is the most central power,
the most powerful central claim of
postmodernism.
A claim which I think is actually
correct.
And which also has be devil,
many other fields,
including surprisingly enough,
artificial intelligence.
The claim is something like there is an
infinite number of ways to interpret
any,
even finite set of phenomena.
And,
and,
and that actually happens to be true.
It's part of the reason why it's been so
difficult for human beings to develop
artificial intelligence and for them to
develop machines that could operate in
real world environments.
Because it turns out that the world is
so complex that perceiving it all
appears virtually impossible.
Technically speaking.
We heard a little bit earlier that the
previous talk about embodied cognition
and one of the ways psychologists are
trying to address the issue of the
impossibility of perception is to note
that perception isn't possible without
situating the mind in a body that has a
certain set of constraints.
We also devote a tremendous amount of
our neurological landscape to see to
sensory processing so that when we look
at the world that can manifest itself in
this self evident way that it appears to
you,
but that doesn't mean that it's a simple
problem.
It's a very complicated problem and the
postmodernist we're technically correct.
There's there's,
there's a near infinite number of ways
to to perceive and interpret a finite
number of phenomena.
Now you see the thing that's interesting
about that claim apart from the fact
that it happens to be technically true
is that you can use it to mountain
assault on any interpretation of
anything whatsoever because there is a
tremendous,
very variability in the number of
interpretations that you could bring to
bear on a situation.
Then you can instantly jump to the
conclusion or expound the proposition
that none of those interpretation should
be privileged,
Amal,
above all,
above any others.
Now that's actually wrong,
and this is why postmodernism is correct
and it's central assumption but
incorrect in its secondary assumption.
Now the reason it's wrong is because
although there is a very large number of
potential interpretations of the world,
that does not mean that there is an
equally large number of viable
interpretations of the world.
Now you might say,
well,
what constitutes constraints on the
viability of an interpretation?
And I would say,
well,
there's a number of them and I think you
have to understand this in the context
of living creatures,
viewing and interpreting the world,
and also within a broader evolutionary
context,
the way that evolution solves the
problem of the infinite number of
potential interpretations is by killing
every single thing that interprets
things badly enough to die.
Right?
And so I,
I mean this,
this is actually one of the most
powerful arguments for the necessity of
the evolutionary reason for the
necessity of the accuracy of the
evolutionary theory.
It's,
it's that it's taken three and a half
billion years of evolution to produce
creatures of our sort who can interpret
the world,
which is impossible to interpret well
enough to live for approximately 80
years and to have some reasonable chance
of propagating during that period of
time,
three and a half billion years.
And that's the best we've been able to
do.
It's a very complicated problem.
And evolution solves that problem by
producing a tremendous number of
variance and then killing almost all of
them.
And so death is the solution to the
problem of interpretation.
And it's a terrible solution,
but the point I'm trying to make there
is that interpretations are constrained
by such things,
primary things that happened to be
relevant to living beings like suffering
and death.
So those are the first sets of
constraints.
Your interpretations of the world should
shield you to the degree possible from
excess suffering and death.
That doesn't seem to be too debatable
proposition unless you're aimed in the
suicidal direction.
And so we can start by merely pointing
that out.
We also might point out that such things
as the necessity for cooperating and
competing with others also constraints
the interpretations that you're allowed
in the world,
especially given that not only do you
have to cooperate and compete with
people one time,
but that you have to cooperate and
compete with often the same people many
times in many different contexts and so
that not only do you have to interpret
the world so that you can cooperate and
compete with those people.
You have to do it in a manner that can
be iterated and repeated and that
constitutes also an extraordinary series
constraints.
So you don't want to suffer too much.
And you don't want to die and you want
to be able to cooperate with people and
you want to be able to compete with them
and you want to be able to do that over
long periods of time.
And then maybe you also want to do it
with an aim in mind because generally we
have aims in mind and so there are
things that we'd like to have more than
other things.
And so we aim at those and then we have
to constrain our interpretation so that
when we enact them in the world,
the probability that what we're aiming
at is going to happen will improve.
And all of those constraints operates
operate simultaneously.
And what that implies.
And I think John Piaget,
the developmental psychologists maybe
went farther along this line of thinking
than anyone else I knew about anyways.
It's sort of an elaboration of cons,
fundamental,
ethical maximum,
which was something like,
um,
act as if the thing that you're doing
will be done by everyone.
And,
but the pig and sense was more like act
as if the thing that you will be doing
needs to be repeated endlessly.
In a manner that moves up instead of
down.
It's something like that,
but the point is is that there's.
There's tremendous constraints on the
manner in which we can interpret the
world from any realistic perspective.
So the criticism that there are an
infinite number of interpretations falls
apart on closer examination.
So that's,
that's the first place that the
postmodernists are seriously wrong.
They radically underestimated the
intrinsic constraints on,
on,
on interpretation.